you're watching a Valley's most accurate
forecast on 8 news now we'll for sure be
keeping an eye on that but you may be
more concerned about the New Year's Eve
weather here but let's stay with the
here and now almost looks like a sunrise
or a sunset but this is a live picture
from our camera near the spaghetti Bowl
looking across that the Strat and the
strip Blue Sky trying to bust on through
the cloud cover officially 51 degrees at
Reed International but we always like to
check in on the temperatures in your
neighborhood and let's see what we got
out there still some 40s along the west
side got a bunch of 52s and when you
have a blanket of cloud cover you're not
going to have a whole lot of temperature
change let's check Nevada and Beyond
much more likely to see rain mixed with
snow up to our neighbors to the north
Death Valley looking at 60 right now
over the hunt and prompt you guys are
54. so we're going to try for 55 today
that'll be the first day in several
where we've not been at 60 or higher for
the afternoon high but that's actually
closer to normal with the cloud cover we
he only dropped down to the low 40s this
morning so what's going on out there
well we mentioned some rain mixed with
snow sneaking underneath us and it is
definitely causing some issues along the
I-15 and Southwestern Utah but here in
town there might be a snowflake way on
top of Mount Charleston but otherwise
we're just going to stay mostly cloudy
with a little bit of sunshine breaking
on through and then the atmospheric
river is still set to rain on our New
Year's Eve parade we'll see what effect
that may or may not have on the
fireworks okay for your family and
friends Across the Nation snow showers
through Nebraska moving on up to the
Northern Plains some scattered showers
across the Deep South your most accurate
eight day forecast taking into the New
Year yes rain Saturday tomorrow's high
also the mid 50s with a cloudy Sky storm
clouds rain May linger into the first
day of 2023 and then another chance for
rain next week Heather wow okay well we
could use the rain it's just not great
timing Nate thank you